also now more what appears to be very
good news coming out of that study on
run Desa vir preliminary data shows that
patients who receive it had a 31% faster
recovery time than those who took a
placebo dr. mark Segal boxers medical
correspondent dr. you doing good day to
you I got a lot of questions here let's
see how much ground we can plow in the
next few minutes REM des severe
how does it work what's the component or
what's in this cocktail Marc bill REM
desapear is an intravenous drug and in
this case it was tried in a thousand
patients that were already very sick and
had pneumonia and that was in 68 centers
around the world they're then going to
try and people that have are less sick
we'll see what happens earlier but
here's how it works
basically a virus goes inside your cell
it hijacks your DNA or your machinery to
replicate all it cares about a virus is
reproducing and then jumping to another
cell well Renda severe is incorporated
in one of the enzymes that the virus
uses to reproduce and once it gets
inside the virus REM that severe it
halts the reproduction it fulls the
virus and the virus hauls that is an
incredible mechanism that seems to
decrease the amount of virus that is
circulating in your body I think yeah
that's why Bill it's deep its deep it's
decreasing from 14 days to 11 days
recovery time that's the key okay dr.
Fauci yesterday said is it's not a
knockout but it looks good how do you
rate it doc well I rate it in terms of
virus recovery time in other words that
difference between 14 days and 11 days
is huge if you're trying to recover from
a life-threatening illness but bill we
need to know what will happen if you
give it earlier in the game am I going
to be able to keep people out of the
hospital with it if I give it
intravenously at home is it going to
shorten hospital courses is it gonna
save lives we don't know yet but if
preliminary studies look like it may
save some lives and that's key okay so
well in your first hand you talked about
the vise it stops the virus from
replicating in the body which which
which stunts the growth which is what
you want to do but they were used
this drug on a bowl a few years ago do
you remember that yes Ebola is a far
different type of virus Ebola is an
incredibly deadly virus this virus for
some reason it makes a lot of
inflammation and blood clots in your
body that's when it gets deadly with
this virus I think you can stop it in
its tracks a lot easier than Ebola
once Ebola gets in there it's almost
impossible to defeat it
okay so last question here if this is
the answer and I still note some
hesitation and the analysis here from
medical experts like yourself Gilead is
gonna have to produce how much of this
hundreds of millions of doses and how
difficult could that be to get it
produced and get it out all over the
world dr. bill first of all I don't know
if it's the answer what I think is it's
it's a weapon it's it's definitely an
arrow in our quiver it's a tool we have
now it's going to save lives
I believe Gilead is going to start by
ramping up about a hundred thousand
treatment courses over the next month by
the end of the year millions of courses
so they're there on the way to making
millions of doses of this that's what's
going to be needed but even a hundred
thousand doses to be used treatment
courses is going to make a big
difference I think it's something
positive here okay are you giving it an
A are you giving it a B what are you
giving it right now doc we're looking
for hope be honest its preliminary I'm
giving it an a-minus its preliminary I'm
very excited that we bill here's the
here's the real headline clinical trials
done this quickly with results on a
thousand patient town this quickly that
show a positive result Wow against the
deadly virus this this is incredible
notice that's the end block will tell K
are a plus a might we're in the right
range Thank You doc good to see a mark
Siegel with us today thank you sir